[Music]
in what a trip news submitted by mascot
of Jamelia what is the mascot Joe just
Joe this is you have a mascot world is
[ __ ] up what's his name Joey Balanta
that's kind of sexy I like that a man
went missing overnight in Disneyland
after a battle SD trip Oh
oh my god that is so amazing really hey
that ride uh not be mad we need to poo
no we need the pool that's an acid I've
never done drugs but I'd imagine if I
did do drugs that was wonderful
you never try any drugs no not marijuana
well really yeah now it is but it's
still drugs doesn't mean Attilio Lee's
caffeine is a drug alcohol is a drug
love is a drug yep that's beautiful
beautiful you know what else is a drug
Disneyland
you're not a so CalPERS you've ever been
to Disneyland no that's beautiful man
what did you like the carnival
what do you mean like the cruise you
know like a muse mint Park yeah like
buck-toothed guys let you throw
baseballs
but I did get it you know what yesterday
are a few weeks ago I got a check from
SeaWorld because they overcharged me too
I never had to see a world pass but I'm
gonna cash the check and everyone's
gonna shut the [ __ ] up wait do you into
SeaWorld I don't know apparently there's
some you don't know if you went to see
where I did did you see a big whale no I
never went to SeaWorld
I've never do you go to any amusement
parks hmm yeah I went to Six Flags do
you like feeling happy yeah but I don't
want to go here found what happiness
amusement parks are always it's
Halloween and we're gonna scare you and
touch your butt and then have you seen a
Disney movie you know it's only
Halloween one day I'm sorry I'm gonna
just say this no y'all know there was
like 30 year old women that are still
obsessed with Disney - don't you don't
know anything but I do really enjoy her
really yeah
old roommate who like would dress up as
dizzy a Disney princess she had a statue
full sleeves of Disney like that's weird
as [ __ ] yeah it Muriel David's really
daunting I'm something like that's a lot
of people but Disney so big now like it
can be any it's our childhood that too
but now it's like Star Wars it's more of
all like I mean all that well you know
who else loves Disneyland this Swiss man
this Swiss man who had the bright idea
to go to Disney World in Paris and
taking LSD well I've done acid it's the
better version of it is it more pure is
it like MDMA versus ecstasy no it's the
same thing it's the yeah it's it's like
say yeah like THC is weed but or like
it's in its the chemical cleaner oh the
acid is LSD is the same [ __ ]
so anyways just a street name you get it
in liquid form you get it like in a
paper tab for high sugar cube they just
put the liquid inside of sugar cane yeah
I've learned a lot about this I remember
when I was a kid there was a there was a
book on drugs that was always checked
out because I had pictures I had a lot
of information and like there was a wait
list for it and I was like is the
librarian concerned because we were all
in elementary school you guys didn't
have the Internet no in elementary
school we were supposed to treat Oh
Elementary yeah yeah but I'm saying like
the librarian if there is a wait list
for a book about drugs
remember index cards I mean they have
the DARE program in elementary so maybe
you're just curious because you just
learned about all these good point they
were like the kids are educating
themselves I don't know there was a book
of drugs in elementary there is this
website that tells you all the horrible
[ __ ] that happens on your rug like
people submit their stories of how all
the horrible [ __ ] and that's why I never
did I think I've been there yeah it's
called heroin every time yes what that
was the name of it every time the
guidance counselor came and everyone
were like the people that are the DARE
program and everyone talked about drugs
and all that it just made me want to
smoke even more I remember I read on
erowid that you could take a bunch of
Dramamine and get high so this girl
stole a - of Dramamine and I took 12 and
I literally tripped for like an entire
day and then like you I can't even it's
like a disc
so she ative drunk chorus i t'ink often
cold those are the Red Devils we did
those what the [ __ ] they got banned
because people were making a mess out of
them well I got caught that's why they
use sudafed I got home and I just walked
in and my mom was sitting in the living
room and I looked right at her and I was
like are you gonna [ __ ] Todd tonight
yeah I just said it I know Bucky no and
even the night before I jumped out of my
window so my mom immediately took me to
the hospital and they made me drink like
charcoal and it was real bad but I
digress now this guy in Disneyland I
mean honestly brawl it's it's we've all
been there before my man took some LSD
and then his group of friends lost him
they lost him and then there was a whole
search party he went with his 30 year
old girlfriend this guy's 32 and there
was a whole search party looking for him
they had 80 Disneyland employees looking
for this no big cameras everywhere [ __ ]
can't they just fun they they didn't
find him until midnight where he had
washed up on the bank of the lake and it
was completely naked and he just had
scratches all over him and he was
barefoot that's the same place to wake
up cuz I feel like he follow us on LSD
the place that I want to go is like once
you get into a ride like you know one of
the ones it's more like themed rather
than a roller coaster you just get up
and you start climbing like the rafters
yeah yeah so you can maybe from
surveillance footage you see them in or
like the Alice in Wonderland light right
and then whatever car comes out is now
empty because this [ __ ] is now
in the behind the scenes and if what you
get behind the scenes of Disneyland it's
gonna be impossible to find dope they
all have like underground like walkways
and shih-tzu they like secret paths
through that [ __ ] find someone Mickey
chair yeah there's Mickey jail boy Vic
throw this [ __ ] it's actually like at
least in Disneyland and Disney World I
don't know about Paris but it's more
high-tech more advanced than even like
our country's surveillance and like
security I wonder if it's like Donald
Duck and a cop outfit and he's like
holding
you jail I was picturing that's a place
for like adults to break the park rules
or if you get to dead it yeah really and
know what I picture it being at two bars
and all to go in that want to get
arrested fun now yeah that sound kind of
sick dude not fun in there I guess after
I don't know cuz if somebody does a vlog
and it says I had to go to jail I'm
clicking on that [ __ ] oh yeah what did
you know you just told them all what to
do I mean it's these kind assets pretty
cool but I I would do it at Disneyland I
think Disneyland is one of those places
where you want to kind of you want a
trip it's like Alice in Wonderland
probably probably well
Disneyland will take care of you because
as soon as they found out that this man
had disappeared though there was a
search party of 35 and fires 10 divers
10 police body right yeah it's in Paris
yeah and if patty 80 Disneyland Paris
and take your shirt police helicopter
and they had a thermal imaging camera
all formed around going through the
water trying to find the man because
they didn't know where he was a camera
helps up because then you could just see
like a Redbox florida cuz he would have
gotten eaten by a crocodile for shock I
don't even think I want to see what his
adventure was like I know right I want
to hear his stories like what did he see
recently my friend's brother like well
he's my friend on Facebook too but it he
he wrote a what everybody call it like a
[ __ ] status update where he was like
I just woke up and I don't know how I
got into this mansion and I don't have
my wallet or whatever and then that was
the last thing I read and I was like
what the [ __ ]
and so I asked him I asked his brother
like hey is your brother all right or
whatever and he goes dude this is what
the [ __ ] happened so apparently he got
himself into a group of interesting
shady motivational speakers right and
they all want to party yeah at night at
Vegas and and so he goes all he
remembers is going to the club and then
drinking and then he wakes up he's in
the mansion with no money and then he
wakes up again and then he's in a car
and then he wakes up and then he's
basically wiping the window of a
terrified lady's car and that's when he
way
he's like that's the last time he woke
up is like he's just [ __ ] doing his
thing where he's wiping the window and
the lady's inside the car like [ __ ]
terrified him you got this gas station
he's like holy crap all the [ __ ] did I
get their hangover dude yeah and he's
he's literally trying to go back and
trace his steps and he doesn't have
anything he only has his phone so he
doesn't
thank God yet that but he doesn't have
his wallet hasn't anything oh yeah well
his teeth no shoes just pants and shirt
that's why don't you drugs no no he got
drugged and he got drugged and jacked
yeah that's why I don't take drinks we
didn't take his fall no that's crazy
yeah but I'm like yeah but he must have
been with his friends because they went
to a mansion party or something but he
woke up in a room and no one remembers
like how he got there where he got there
half of the people he might have made
friends and they took him there and I
was like was his [ __ ] okay yeah yeah
I hope so
you know I'm not gonna lie condone drugs
I kind of mean yeah I'm not gonna say
that drugs are good but recently I was
sick and I took an IKE wall and it made
me feel really good I slept all night
and I think that that was the first time
I had gotten like the amount of sleep
you're supposed to get I think I had
been shaving off a half an hour each
night like seven half and I got ten
hours of sleep and I woke up and I was
just like present like any filler
present but I want to get there without
nyquil meditate I do what does he sleep
booked like 30 minutes I just wake up
with anxiety every day but this would
like well I didn't have anxiety for the
first time in years and I just felt like
I was present I could only I only
focused on one task if it wasn't night
cool it was probably you forgiving
yourself for being six or not pushing
yourself really I think he's like you
[ __ ] you better push harder now
cuz you gotta make up for all the [ __ ]
that you didn't do but this time I was
like I gotta do one task at a time and I
was so behind but I was I got everything
done you keep taking nyquil right now
cool house think I will alcohol your
night was a way different drug I feel
like then ending up naked in a beach in
Disneyland true
I know you don't want to push drugs on
these people but you know what's good
though robitussin and drink half of that
[ __ ] bottle or two nyquil don't drink
half the bottle bow tripping geo it's a
thing it's cheap efficient and infor
don't do that you guys well Dobby don't
do that don't do that no I mean like
obviously they were kind of worried
about him but no they found him and they
found him they took him to his house
gave him clothes see cuz they weren't
worried about like if it happened here
people will be pissed that he used city
resources to find him then they just
arrested him
oh they arrested you should pay
something though if you decide to get
[ __ ] up and then you pay a fine they
detained him but they released him by
for it what's France yeah I'm surprised
I got out cuz I feel like people died
Disneyland and stuff and Disneyland like
covers up all those from the roller
Coster yeah like and you'll hear about
it or someone did die do you mean
someone did die from a gator last year I
think oh yeah this summer I was looking
at that beach I was like a kid just died
right yeah like a two-year-old
they got a damn alligator Disneyland is
so scary we talked about that
Disneyland's better at keeping people
quiet that North Korea is yeah hush
those stories so much they got so much
power you know all the places that are
associated with happy times and vacation
and tourism liars quiet yeah there's a
lot of death yeah that's why I like to
enjoy tropical vacations and Vegas but
there's a lot of death there oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]